when someone is struggling or in need
all they need is 8 minutes from a friend
to hold space with them to make them
feel better and so now we have a code
word when one of us is struggling the
text is do you have 8 minutes and that
simply means I need you I'm going to cry
there is no greater honor that you could
give a friend than to send them a text
message that says do you have 8 minutes
like when you're in your own
like Darkness there is no
greater gift to let someone know how
much they mean to you to send that text
there's no greater honor there is no
greater like that is the level friend
that I aspire to be and I don't have a
zillion friends because I'm like the
friends I have I'm the 8 Minute text in
the middle of the night friends I'm the
stop drop and roll
friends